peter what do you got for us buddy
hi rich
how you doing
good i just wanted to say first off i
read your book a few months ago and it's
it really helped me out i started
reading rollo and watching all those
podcasts and i'm i'm far from
i'm pretty early in my journey and being
red pill but i just wanted to say thank
you okay i think my question's been
somewhat addressed but i'll still ask it
so i just i have no sexual experience
and but
really anxious to end that drought but
do you think is sexual experience really
worth pursuing if i have not reached my
my excellence potential so to speak 26
right
yes
you gotta deal with that anxiety
yeah yeah we'll talk about that in a bit
but i mean like why haven't you been you
know dealing with women at all
um
well the usual culprits i had a single
mother i also grew up in a very
religious family i grew up catholic
not that i'm criticizing people who are
religious but it wasn't a healthy
state of mind for me it set me back lots
of guilt yeah i
where do you live by the way in what
state
i live in florida and what do you do for
a living
i'm an engineer i work in the space
industry okay so you make some good
money right
it's okay
it's okay my potential is
i work for the government so my
potential to earn is
attenuated okay all right and you're in
good shape i mean i don't see a lot of
fat on your face i'm assuming that
you're not you know shaped like a pear
right
no i'm in decent shape my body fat i got
it measured recently and it's around 15
which it could be better but okay so
this is a game issue like this is a
calibration issue right yeah
right um do you think it's do you think
it's worth pursuing that or should i
just yeah that's dude like yeah dude
like it adds watch watch watch eddie
murphy okay i can't remember if it's
delirious or raw but your 20s are your
years to f
okay
those are going to be your best years
well not only that man it's a skill set
that you have to develop once again and
if you're avoiding developing that skill
set true it doesn't get easier it gets
harder
to vet out
what girls want you for genuine desire
and what girls are going to want you for
your other smv qualities particularly
your wallet okay so if you wait until
you're really doing well financially and
like killing though you know whether
you're a government contractor making
you know multiple six figures all this
stuff have all nice toys nice house now
i'm ready for a wife right we talked
about this just right before you got on
that's not a good recipe dude because
they're going to go for you sure for
your wallet and it's not going to be
good
it's not going to turn out well for you
yeah you really have to calibrate to
like today's women to understand what
they're all about because they are
absolutely nothing like what you think
the church or your mom told you they're
supposed to be like yeah i've had i've
had a lot of
ex i've had a few bad experiences i i
will say one point of anxiety is i'm i'm
five foot six and i'm really short and i
used to really blame that on my failure
of women instead of owning up to the
things that's gonna threaten you paul
short paul schwartz five three five foot
one miles four foot eight yeah he's not
even like six months old right he does
he does
i'm an engineer
height is not as important as you think
like if you're five foot six you can
easily date a five foot two check just
as long as she's looking up to you yeah
definitely because right you're what
you're doing right now as far as dating
apps and stuff like that are you like on
tinder bumble hinge what are you doing
it's not like you're swiping or do you i
i went on one hinge date and it was so
awful i deleted everything he's just
thinking about it right now i don't
think he's doing that
no i i'm really i've never
done it beyond that okay do you have a
crew do you have a tribe do you have a
bunch of guys
um
i've moved every couple years for my
career so my life is pretty fragmented
but i have a couple good friends every
place i've lived but what do you do for
fun when you're not
working work a lot but i'm it's mostly
exercise
lately it's been mostly reading books
are you interacting with women when
you're exercising like you're part of a
gym or uh
yeah i joined a crossfit gym okay
there's lots of chicks in crossfit
several months ago
not in florida
so go to a gym where there's more women
like uh he's in the government he's
probably up in the panhandle race you
know where there's a lot of you know
there's a lot of women and it's a good
workout they um
they call them nine rounds here i don't
know what they call them in estates but
they're basically 30 minute boxing um
sessions and they're always calibrated
by
a trainer it's a honeypot there's it's
like it's like 80 it's like 80 women
right i mean like you kind of have to go
to where the fish are i mean if you're
fishing and you want to catch a fish you
kind of have to go to where the fish are
but if you're surrounded by sausages and
all you're doing is hanging out by
yourself and you know you don't get that
exposure you're not going to be able to
calibrate to women and have
conversations because i mean like the
first thing that you got to deal with is
have a comfortable drink or a coffee or
whatever it is you're going to do with a
chick and walk away at the end of it
where she's like hey peter i dig your
vibe you know can you call me again so i
can see you soon
right that's like the first step you
know forget about you know getting laid
and losing the v card and all that like
the first step is calibrating to
conversations with women good
right yeah and just i want you to shift
your mental focus here be be
uncomfortable with this and that's okay
all right because you need to be
uncomfortable
in order to get comfortable you know
what i mean to start developing those
skill sets and consider it something
that is a priority to work on you know
what i mean and it's instead of avoiding
it and that's that's because again
you're you're going to run into a
problem
as you do increase in your in your
wealth and what you're doing you know
you're probably a very smart guy you
probably aren't on the road to doing
very well
you're going to run into that problem
where
you're not going to be able to decipher
who who's actually wants you for you and
who's wanting to
run you through the machine and you need
to figure that out now it's a process of
figuring it out as you grow but the
analogy i wanted to use real quick
though was imagine if i said dude don't
go to the gym or think about your diet
for the next seven years because you got
to work on your money situation that
would be really bad right like that'd be
potentially bad you know and so you're
not but is the gym the focus of your
whole life no no right it's just
something you do because you're working
on it and it's a priority to take care
of your your body right and you know
take care of your mental fitness all
that stuff should be a priority and this
should be a priority too it's not the
main one you're not chasing women you're
just working on your skills man and just
shift that over a little bit you got a
lot of good content out there you got my
channel rich's channel here and you can
start working on those skills and
finding which road you want to go to
it's not a it's not a race it's a
marathon it's not about just getting
laid it's about getting better you know
what i mean i would i would start by
putting yourselves in rooms where you
can have comfortable conversations with
women and not feel anxious about it so
that might be workout stuff that might
be like i don't know like some other
hobby that you like but put yourself an
environment where there's women that
you're attracted to where you can just
have a casual conversation where anxiety
doesn't kick in you don't start to
stutter or anything like that it's just
comfortable and then it'll get to the
point where it's like hey you know what
you know i just had a ton of fun today
why don't we uh take this conversation
over to that bar over there and have a
drink
right and just kind of sit down outside
of that you know kind of work
you know hobby sort of zone and make it
more into like a date zone
and then you do another venue change
which can be like hey you know my place
is two blocks that way why don't you
come over i got some wine in the fridge
and that's when you start to escalate
yeah i mean like you gotta get to like
step step one but you just have to do it
right you just have to get out there and
start doing it like just
get comfortable with it
i think about this too man like you're
invited we were all dorks at one point
too like all of us here we all like you
know we're in that same anxious zone
that you were
still in
paul's paul's still there but i mean
like you know for some of us it was
until we were like 18 19 20 20 you know
for you just happens to be 26 you just
kind of have to push through it you just
have to lean into it and is the life
that you're creating for yourself one
that a chick is going to want to join
you into are you going to bring her in a
situation where she's going to have fun
and she's going to associate good
feelings fun feelings with you like
jared and i have this thing where it's
like we'll tell girls like you'll never
be bored if anything if nothing else
you'll always have fun and you'll never
be bored so i mean i know you like to
work a lot it sounds like you're
stacking cash and being an engineer and
can tell you're probably not you know
it's not a super interactive with people
and very front-facing all the time kind
of job
but you know that other kind of stuff
like what you're doing for fun your
social settings things like that i mean
you live in florida for god's sakes you
know the weather's great so
it's you know
what life are you creating
that someone is going to look at you be
like all right i want to see what this
guy's about and i want to join into that
because that looks fun
but um
peter
i'm just saying
the the chapter in sorry to interrupt
you the chapter in rich's book that
stood out to me the most was the chapter
about the motorcycle
was that jeffy or did you buy one
i really want to buy one yeah go get one
we'll get one yeah listen good one for
sure
peter
peter i'm a catholic engineer as well
okay
and just going back to what paul said he
can't emphasize that enough you're 26
you're a sharp looking guy you have a
steady job a good career if you don't
get on top of this now it's going to
rain baby rabies on you in about four
years and these chicks eggs are going to
start their clock is going to start
ticking and they're going well he's a
good guy peter he's clean he's cut he's
nice they'll marry you up and and it's
going to be a train wreck
they'll marry you up and take your kids
and half your and see you later
about seven years down the road so peter
that's what's going to say you're you're
a good looking guy you're sharp you're
well spoken you're clearly educated you
told me what you working i worked in
that industry too so i have an idea of
what kind of money you're making there's
no there's no reason you should have any
sort of problems with women so it's on
your head man it's it's the anxiety that
you really have to deal with you know
that all the time and really just build
get your reps in build your confidence
talk get your reps in exactly you know
how easy it is to deal with anxiety
you know how easy it is to deal with
anxiety and women when you got a
motorcycle it's so easy dude it's like
all like chick like chicks love bikes
like just get a spare helmet and just
like chat them up and be like hey i got
a bike and let's go for a ride let's go
down to the beach it's like you know i
know this place and you just you know go
for zero you need to make them feel feel
good emotions so even if you're in the
line at a coffee shop and there's
something that happens make a little
witty comment a little whatever and then
just get in the habit train your brain
of when there's a female present she
feels good around me and then that'll
naturally start escalating and even if
you're kind of nervous you know your
first initial encounters
a lot of these chicks like
they a lot of them just kind of a lot of
them try to lead the way anyways for me
half the problem with american chicks
it's like hey i got it like hold on
all right
in the community man like chris amy's in
the chat i don't know if you see this if
he's serious take him up on his offer
he's saying he'll pay for you to join
the community so you don't get that you
don't get that very many places man
there's there's the url well it will be
getting to the top comment if you want
to come into that community it's open be
prepared to do work don't don't show up
and you know
expect the uh entire road map to be
handed to you you have to engage okay
we just lost a guy today for the same
exact reason that you probably need to
get in there because we go real really
deep into this stuff
all right um pete
just just get started right like you
know how do you eat an elephant just one
bite at a time you just get started
right
okay all right man thank you
you